[Music]
me complicated
it's funny it's not don't you make me
confidence it's true love
couldn't be this complicated Kim
Kardashian shares a sweet glimpse into
her jam-packed weekend with her kiddos
and honestly it's the adorable wholesome
content we all need I just think like
we're definitely a close family over the
weekend the skims founder posted this
clip featuring her four-year-old
daughter Chicago singing in the back
seat of the car with her three-year-old
brother Saul
love
shouldn't be this complicated
the two are belting out their famous dad
Kanye West track true love true love
[Music]
should it be this complicated
[Applause]
[Music]
don't you make me confidence and true
love
wouldn't be this complicated it's the
way shy checks her little bro for me
though
it's complicated having kids is just
there's no way to describe it but it's a
lot Kim who filed for divorce from yay
in 2021 posted the video just days after
the Grammy winner went off on social
media airing his grievances with his ex
over parenting issues alleging that Kim
kept him from seeing Chicago on her
birthday earlier this year Acclaim Kim
adamantly denies you just gotta roll
with it true love which the rapper
co-wrote with
xxxtentacion references the former
couples four kids
who watch in Chicago and you know all
the nannies that Danny Nebraska Kim
captioned the brother sister moment
quote OMG they are just so cute I had to
share I don't know what's gonna top that
[Music]
but will they follow in yay's musical
footsteps I hope that they just find
their own motivation and no matter what
that is no matter what they want to do
in life I hope that they work really
hard our kids will see you know Kanye
and I work really hard and I hope that's
motivating for them and just to find
their own path I think to not pressure
but to definitely have our our rules
um is the best that you can do and while
Chicago and Saul were flexing their
vocal chops Kim and Kanye's six-year-old
son Saint was all about sports
it's really fun to see on Sunday the
reality star hit up the LA Rams game
with her eldest son I am so busy doing
so many other things I want to make sure
each kid gets so much of my attention I
think four is the perfect magic number
for me the
weird on the home
the home private box before stepping out
on the field and getting an up close and
personal look at the Rams 2022 Super
Bowl trophy look at how cool
just to show you
so whether she's driving the kids around
or taking them to a football game Kim's
all about being a mama to her kids
my house is so full but in the best way
it's it's amazingly full and to send you
off here's Chicago and Psalms backseat
duet one more time
[Music]
it's sunny it's not don't you make me
confidence it's true love
shouldn't be this complicated
hello
[Music]